a california policeman was intentionally
playing taylor swift
during a confrontation with a black
lives matter activist with the idea that
if they were playing copyrighted music
then the video of this confrontation
could no longer be hosted on places like
youtube
playing my music so this has
hilariously backfired because this video
is absolutely everywhere but the
question is
is it copyright infringement and the
answer is probably not though this is a
very very interesting question because
when we talk about fair use we talk
about the
recognized categories things like
commentary criticism and education and
this doesn't really fall into any of the
enumerated categories that we know of
but
fair use was specifically designed by
congress to be non-exclusive and i think
if this case
ever went to the court a judge would
take one look at and say this is for a
political purpose there's no copyright
infringement intended and yes the cop
can try and get away with it but they're
not going to the video is going to be
promoted pretty much everywhere so if
you're a police officer
i wouldn't recommend doing this or will
see you in court